[Music]
warning this video contains cold B ah
spoilers all the spoilers all of them
what is up everybody its Anna Mac here
for anime uproar and welcome to a brand
new cold Geass video in this video we're
going to be talking about everything we
know about Geass power and how it works
we're also going to be talking about all
the known Geass users what their Geass
power is and what its limitations are
this has been a big project we've been
working on this one for a while but with
the Code Geass sequel coming out
sometime in the future I thought it
would be a great idea to put everything
we know about Geass power and all the
non Geass users in one place so you can
keep coming back to this video whenever
you need to I had a lot of help with
this video from some of our active
members on discord and I'm going to be
shouting them out at the end of the
video but I want to give a quick thank
you just ban some age who really went
out of his way to help me on this one
thanks buddy I appreciate it if you're
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
for all the latest code geass season 3
news and theories and if you want to
chat with us on a daily basis and
contribute to future videos you can join
our discord server link in the
description now the word Geass comes
from the Irish word geese and an Irish
mythology at least is a prohibition or
an obligation similar to being under a
bow or a spell a DS can be compared with
a curse or paradoxically a gift if
someone is under akise and violates the
Associated taboo the in fracture will
suffer dishonor or even death on the
other hand the observing of one piece is
believed to break power often it is
women who plays Geass upon men in some
cases the woman turns out to be a
goddess or other type of magical
creature which of course reminds us of
c2 and her contract with Lelouch Geass
power is gained to a contract with an
immortal being with code we can assume
that these immortal beings with code
were once Geass users themselves and
that they received code from their own
contractors want their Geass power reach
a certain level however we are not sure
whether a Geass user can only gain code
from their own contractor
person that gave them Geass or whether
they can gain it from any being with
cold the big theory about how Lelouch
actually survived the end of r2 is that
he became immortal by taking the code
away from Charles and of course we know
that Charles is not the lucious
contractor c2 is there is no known
example in the series of AES user taking
code from someone other than their own
contractor however we can speculate that
that might theoretically be possible
this contract between a mortal and a
being with code gives the mortal the
Geass power to fulfill their greatest
wish or example in the case of c2 her
greatest wish was to be loved because
she grew up as an orphan without a
family and her Geass power was to make
people love her Lelouch his greatest
wish was to not be helpless and to have
the power to make the world a peaceful
place for Nunnally so of course his
Geass power was to have power over other
people
Charles's greatest wish was to change
the world and to rid the world of lies
and deceit so his Geass power was to
change other people's memories and shin
Hyuga shang from our t2d exile believed
that life was occurred and he wanted to
save the people he loved from the curse
of life so his Geass power was actually
to make the people he loves killed
himself it is important to mention that
Geass power increases the more it is
used and in the case of someone like Mao
his Geass power actually went out of
control and made him mentally unstable
it is also important to mention that EOS
power does not work on a code bear on a
being with code and every Geass power is
tailored specifically to the greatest
wishes and ambitions of that particular
Geass user what's more every Geass power
has its own unique limitation and we
will talk about every known Geass user
their particular Geass power and its
limitations later on in this video we
also know that everyone on whom Geass is
used must understand the concept of what
is being asked from them so it is a form
of mind control and manipulation rather
than some all-powerful magical
phenomenon we learned this in a key to
the Exile when Iquitos brother shin
tries to kill everyone in his household
by using his Geass on
ah Tito is the only person who does not
die even after Shane uses Geass on him
because akuto is too young at this point
to understand the concept of death the
only potential exceptions to the rule
that yes is some sort of manipulation of
the mind are the powers of - from the
Renia of the darkness manga and laila
from Akito the exiled another
interesting thing that we learn from
Akito the exiled is that a kiosk
contract may not require a beam with
code that has a physical body because
shin appears to receive his Geass from a
disembodied skull a sort of vision of a
skull rather than a code bear with a
physical body and for more information
on this skull and what it might be you
can check out our top ten mysteries in
Code Geass video link in the description
and now we're going to talk about photos
and on Geass users what their Geass
power is and what its limitations are in
this case we are only looking at
canonical Geass users which means that
we are looking at the original Code
Geass series the aki - the exiled ova
and all the reflection and ran out the
darkness manga these are all spin-offs
that do not conflict with the events and
the timeline of the original series
which is why we are considering them
Canon as opposed to other spin-offs like
nightmare of not only for example which
clearly changes the events at the time
under the original series and for that
reason we do not consider it canon and
what better place to start than Lelouch
VI Britannia his Geass power is forcing
someone to obey a particular command
when making direct eye contact with them
his limitations include the fact that he
has to make direct eye contact and that
he can only use this power one on any
single person the only plausible
exception is if someone has been
affected by Jeremiah's Geass Chancellor
we believe that the Geass has remained
the gave Lelouch India which would allow
him to then use his Geass power once
again on the same person if that person
was first affected by the Geass can slit
see to her Geass power before she
received cold what to make those around
her fall in love with her the specific
limitation of her power are unknown we
do not
enough information however we are
speculating that she is possibly unable
to turn off her power just like Mao
couldn't turn off his charles zi
britannia his Geass power is altering a
person memory with this power he is able
to suppress the Geass of another user
and even the physical senses such as
sight his limitations include that he
has to make direct eye contact and that
his Geass can potentially be broken
without a VR counselor as appeared to be
the case with Nunnally Mari on V
Britannia
her Geass power is transferring her
consciousness along with her Geass into
another person's body she could take
control of the hosts body from time to
time and she also has the ability to
communicate telepathically with Z to her
limitations include that she has to make
direct eye contact and it is speculated
that she can only use this power when
she is about to die in order to save
herself Mao is the us power is hearing
the conscious thoughts of anyone within
500 meters so the equivalent of mind
reading his limitations include that his
Geass works only within 500 meters in
distance and 300 meters in height and
when the Geass reaches a certain level
it cannot be turned off which has led
Mao to mental instability Rolo Rolo
Geass is stopping the sense of time for
all individuals within a certain radius
effectively paralyzing them the range
varies depending on the situation role
of limitations include that his
heartbeat stops while using the Geass
which puts a great physical strength on
his body we can also assume that
although the range of his Geass is
expensive such as the entire Ashford
campus it cannot possibly be the entire
world so his range has to be limited
bismarck volt speed his Geass power is
seeing up to a few seconds into the
future which allows him to predict the
moves of his opponents in battle however
his power may actually be to predict the
mental intent
of his opponents rather than seeing into
the actual future for his limitations
we know that when not using his Geass
his eyelid is actually sewn shut which
implies that he cannot turn off his yep
and the final die accuser in the Code
Geass series is an unnamed child that is
part of the Geass order the Geass of
this child appears to be to control the
body of another person against their
will with the use of hand gesture for
the limitations even though we only see
this child briefly we can assume that
direct eye contact is required and since
hand gestures and eye contact are
required to manipulate the other
person's movement we can also assume
that it can be used only on one person
at a time and now we will discuss the
characters ending all of the reflection
manga or ph7 is the US is to trick all
people within a certain radius into
thinking that he is someone else he
looks and sounds exactly like the other
person his limitations include that he
has a time limit of 5 minutes and must
take time to recharge if he uses his
Geass power more than twice the range of
his Geass is also assumed to have a
limit though the exact limit is not
known finally his Geass cannot fool
cameras as they do not have a
consciousness that can be manipulated so
someone watching him through a camera
would still see him and not who he's
pretending to be Clara lung from her
power is forcing someone's body to obey
her every command when she calls out
that person's name she only controls the
physical body and not the mind of this
versus her limitations include that she
must call out the person's real name if
a different name is spoken the Geass
will have no effect total Thompson her
Geass is erasing the memories for
another person her limitations include
that she must remove her glasses in
order to make direct eye contact and
that unlike Charles she cannot create
false memories only erase existing ones
and marybelle Mel Britannia her Geass is
to permanently inflame another person
and turn them into a mindless doll her
limitation is that she cannot undo her
command once it is definitively given
and moving on to Akio DXL OVA we have
shin Hyuga Chang whose Geass is
commanding those he loves to kill
themselves or to kill others his
limitations are that is Dion only works
on individuals that you love and the
individual in question must understand
the concept of death in order for to be
up to work Leyla mal call her Geass is
very mysterious and we do not have a lot
of information about it however we do
have a series I believe that her Geass
is protecting the ones she loves
by connecting their minds to create a
mini collective consciousness and this
allows her to manipulate even physical
reality and this is why the larger
collective consciousness singles her out
as unique in the final episode of Akiko
the exile in terms of her limitation my
theory is that it only takes effect a
prayer life or the life of someone she
loves
is in danger and finally in the Renia of
the darkness manga we have Lorenzo Ilsa
let's see his Geass is projecting
illusion in order to make people see
what he wants them to see the illusion
can affect multiple people at once his
limitations are not known to us however
we can assume that he has to make direct
eye contact and shielding her Geass is
reversing the order of priority in a
person's heart so for example she makes
Lorenzo change his mind about killing
Claire Li Britannia her limitation is
that she cannot change a person's entire
mindset only their first priority in
life and those are all the known
canonical Geass users but I want to
mention Jeremiah Gottwald as well he has
an artificial Geass canceller which he
can use on all people affected by yet
within a certain range however if the
effects can be negated with the guy Fung
disturber I want to give a quick thank
you to all our also members on this
Court who helped out with this video
including as I mentioned phantom h but
also know digit vector Maximus soul maka
Otero Hamlet the Dane Jeremiah Emperor
Lelouch and Emilia is best girl thanks a
lot everybody
there has also been a lot of speculation
recently does
corgis season 3 could feature different
and higher forms of Geass power in the
code geass sequel pv we see a kiosk that
appears to flash green briefly before
turning reddish again and this has led
many to speculate that green Geass could
be a different perhaps higher form of
Geass power now I personally think that
different and higher forms of Geass are
definitely a possibility for Code Geass
season 3 the anata to the exiled we
actually see a mysterious being that
does not have a physical form manifests
the four Leila and when she talks to
Leila she tells her that humans only
possessed a small fragment of Geass
power and that humans cannot even
comprehend the true nature of Ghia to me
this suggests that we might discover
more fragments of yachts and higher
levels of Geass in the sequel which
would be really interesting I can't wait
to find out and that is it for this
video guys thank you so much for
watching thanks for all your support and
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell for all the latest
news and theories about Code Geass
season 3 if you want to chat with us on
a daily basis and contribute to future
videos you can join our discord server
link in the description and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]